hey this is sarah with
registerednessrn.com and today i'm going
to show you how to start an iv in my
previous videos i've showed you how to
prepare your iv kit and how to find a
vein on a patient and a different size
of iv gauge needles so if you haven't
watched those you probably want to watch
those videos before you actually watch
this um so today we have miss smith and
we're gonna she's our mannequin and
we're gonna start an iv on her
before you ever start an iv you want to
get your supplies um here's what i have
for my supplies we have a 22 ivy gauge
needle
and extension tubing that will connect
to the cannula of the iv you can use a
cap it's whatever your preference is
a saline flush to prime the line and to
ensure that our iv is patent once we get
it and an iv start kit that contains our
tourniquet or cleaning supplies or tape
everything and of course a pair of
gloves
after you gather your supplies
go to your patient and explain to them
what you'll be doing explain what the iv
will be used for
how it's inserted the pain they're going
to feel a little bit of pain and
just talk to them and share let them
share their concerns with you because a
lot of patients they hate starting an iv
where i work um we get outpatients and
the very first thing we have to do is
start an iv and they say if i knew that
i was getting an iv i probably wouldn't
even came for the test so people really
hate ivs
so what i'm going to do first is i'm
going to get my tubing set up and i'm
going to put the tourniquet on the
patient and look for a vein
so your kit comes with your tourniquet
i have a video on how to put a
tourniquet on a patient before you start
an iv or draw blood there's a trick to
that so what you want to do is i like to
put my tourniquet
above the bend of the arm and
just do tie that with a quick release
and i like to have the patient
sort of put their arm down
so gravity will have the blood pulling
the extremities
and have the patient pump the fist
miss smith can't find purpose because
she's a mannequin but in a real person
when that happens the veins will engorge
and you'll be able to find them
typically where i like to look i like to
look in the ac region or the hand and
people like to do the forearm it's
really your preference what you've got
good at every year over the years so
here's the ac area and in the hands i
like miss smith's hand vane so we're
going to go with that
and while that vein is getting nice and
engorged that's going to help you
whenever a vein is nice and puffy that
decreases your chances of missing the
vein because a lot of times the veins
like to go flat and really just miss
them and you have to try again
so while our veins getting nice and
engorged we're going to get our hip
prepped
and get her extension tubing blush so
i've done hand hygiene so i'm going to
put my gloves on
and always be careful while you're
messing with your supplies because you
don't want to contaminate it because
this is going in the bloodstream
and you don't want it to introduce any
germs into the blood
so like what i like to do first is i
like to prime my extension tubing or my
cap just to get the air out of the
extension tubing so i'm going to get the
tubing out
and get my saline flush
and these are pre-filled flushes i love
it because i remember a long time ago
you had to draw up your own saline so i
love pre-filled saline plushies saline
flush has a bubble in it you have to
prime it and get the bubble out you
don't want to inject that air in the
patient so what you do is you just take
the plunger and you just push it up and
have a little bit saline come out you're
going to screw this onto your extension
tubing extension tubings vary by
hospital settings
and so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to screw that in on the side
and i'm going to flush my tubing just to
get any air out and it will leak a
little bit that's good that means that
you're flushing the tubing i'm going to
keep my saline screwed onto this
extension tubing and this cap on just to
keep it
clean because whenever you actually
start your ivy you don't want to be
fumbling trying to screw your saline on
while you're holding an iv down to
prevent blood from coming out so i just
take that and i just put that back into
the
little packaging
next what i like to do is i like to get
my tape ready
so take your tape out
and i peel
i don't know about four to five inches
off
and i like to
tear it in half because i use these two
pieces to secure the iv line
in place people do it differently this
is just how i do it
i like to just set that aside
because i know i'll be using that
next and gloves and tape do not go
together
there we go
next i'm going to clean the site
in your kit um this kit
came with betadine and alcohol prep a
lot of the other kids are coming with
chlorhexidine it's like a really strong
alcohol that kills germs but this kit
did not come with it if your kit does
come with betadine make sure your
patient isn't allergic
so i'm going to take this alcohol and
i'm going to clean the side i'm going to
clean it
about 10 to 15 seconds in a circular
motion
really killing any germs or any normal
flora that's on her skin so i don't want
to introduce that into the bloodstream
whenever i go to insert the iv so we're
getting that nice and clean
and
then you let it completely dry
don't blow on it because when you blow
on it you're gonna put your germs on it
i've seen people do that don't blow on
it just let it
air dry itself
and be getting your iv ready this is a
22 gauge um miss smith is just going to
be having some basic testing sheets so
she doesn't need an 18 gauge or a 20
gauge she won't be getting blood so
we're just going to do a basic 22. so
it's always good to test what size iv
you need to start on your patient
because patients do not like to be stuck
with an iv and then you come and tell
them oh the doctors ordered a ct with p
protocol you need an 18 gauge so always
try to do the right gauge needle
so what we're going to do i like on
these plastic cannulas again your
hospital will vary on what they have but
i like to just move that around because
sometimes there's like this little glue
on it and when you go to advance it
won't advance so just sort of break that
seal a little bit
okay
so we're gonna start our iv
so we have our vein there
it's good for the patient to make a fist
sometimes prevent those hand veins from
rolling because handmades like to roll
so
have your patient make a fist if it is a
roller and i see the vein right there so
i'm just going to go in
okay
now once you go in you ask yourself how
do i know i'm in the vein
look in this little chamber right here
in this chamber you will see blood start
to collect that is a great sign that
means that you have hit the bank
sometimes you can see the blood come up
through the cannula
and that means you hit the vein
so once that happens what you need to do
is just advance just a little bit more
just a little
push because i have noticed i hit the
vein when i hit the vein i try to
advance the cannula like that
and it won't advance even though i'm in
the vein typically what you do if you
advance it puts the needle a little bit
better in the vein because normally the
needle is just right
barely in the vein when you try to put
the candle in it doesn't go so just
insert just a little bit more
and then slide your cannula in you can
use this
tip right here to slide it in
and this plastic candle is sliding off
of your needle and it's going in the
vein
and your needle is going to stay with
you now after you do that see this
button that is a safety that's to
protect you hit this
and your needle goes straight into this
chamber protects you from any sticks and
you put this in your sharp spots
okay we have that normally blood will
start gushing out so you need to just
hold above where the candle is like that
with your thumb and it'll prevent the
blood from coming out i remember when i
was first starting ivs i would have a
huge mess because i wouldn't do that so
always put your hand right there and
while you're doing that go over to
your extension tubing
and
take the cap off that and just screw
into this part right here
always screw this
very snugly because a lot of times i've
been giving medications because i work
in a testing area and the iv wasn't
screwed on very well and um we have to
give radioactive isotope and from where
the person who started the ivy didn't
screw it on well it would leak so always
make sure you have that screwed on well
and we're going to flush with the saline
flush
in the iv and what you're looking for is
you're looking for it to puff up around
the side if it starts to puff up that's
a bad sign that means that your iv is
infiltrated and the saline is going in
the tissues and not in the vein take it
out and do a new iv
or if it's burning the patient because
sometimes the iv will be infiltrated and
you won't see it puffing up
and it'll be infiltrated even though you
don't see it because the patient's
telling you oh that's burning really bad
because the saline's in there think
about when you get salt in your eyes it
burns so if saline gets
in the tissues it's going to burn now
it's normal for the patient to say oh it
feels like something's dripping down my
arm or it's cold or i taste it or i
smell it that's a great slime that means
it's in the vein so we flushed it and
it's in there so what we're going to do
is we're just going to take the saline
off
and we're going to tape our iv down
that is another important part you
always want to take your iv down good
because i remember one time i worked
really hard and getting my iv
and i didn't tape it down right and the
patient got up to use the bathroom and
lost their iv and i had to do another
one
so i like to take my tape and
put it underneath
this part the cannula part
and tape and gloves do not go together
i'm just going to tape it down about
right there first so i can secure it
and i'm going to take this other piece
of tape that i tore and
just put it underneath this
and i like to just lace it around it
ah these gloves and tape are so sticky
okay then i am going to put the tegaderm
on it
that
and we'll just tape it down a little bit
more
and always clamp this part off so blood
won't pull in there
and you have to really peel this tape
back
so it'll stick
there we go
and sometimes it's really good to secure
it with some tegaderm
kids didn't come with tiger durham for
some reason so we won't have that but
always put your tegaderm around that and
clamp your thing and put your date and
time on it so the oncoming nurses
or anyone who takes the patient will
know
when you started it what gauge it is and
i know in the computer we can chart it
so always pop your tourniquet off after
you're done
and we're done so that's how you start
an iv on a patient
and
if you have any questions or anything be
sure to visit my website
registerednessonline.com because that's
where um you can find all the articles
you need about nursing skills and talk
about nursing we have a forum where you
can connect with others so thank you so
much for watching if you like this video
please share it with others